à cet après midi nouveau débat tout de
suite je vais vous demander de repartir
tranquillement on va accueillir cinq
invités de nouveaux journalistes le
temps qu'il s'installe je vous présente
tout de suite la quatrième
circonscription du doubs celle
d'audincourt pont de roide une
circonscription qui a la particularité
d'accueillir la plus grande usine
automobile de france celle de psa
sochaux et de nombreuses entreprises
industrielles le député sortant vous le
voyez c'est frédéric barbier élu lors
d'une législative partielle en février
2015 afin de remplacer à l'assemblée
nationale pierre moscovici nommé
commissaire européen cette
circonscription au premier tour de la
présidentielle a largement placé marine
le pen en tête au premier tour avec 31
et demi pour cent des suffrages c'est
son deuxième meilleur score régional
après la 2e circonscription en de haute
saône marine le pen qui vous le voyait
devancé de 12 points emmanuel macron
suis dans l'ordre jean luc mélenchon
françois fillon benoît hamon et nicolas
dupont aignan à mes côtés m'a rejoint
christophe bec de france bleu bonjour
christophe georget dans la botte gratien
michaud à 2 à l'est républicain cristal
je vous laisse nous présenter nos cinq
nouveaux invités
alors on va commencer par le député
sortant faire une barbier vous êtes en
sortant élu sur votre nom en 2015 lors
d'une législative partielle ultra
médiatisé mais vous avez siégé pendant
une grande partie de ce mandat puisque
vous étiez le suppliant de pierre
moscovici promu ministre l'économie vous
êtes aussi conseiller départemental dans
le canton de valentigney sur le plan des
étiquettes vous avez la double
investiture vous l'avez retrouvé ps en
marche face avoue sophie montel vous
êtes députée européenne chef de file du
groupe front national au conseil
régional de bourgogne franche comté
vous vivez de la politique depuis vingt
ans après vous être présenté à de
nombreuses élections c'est votre
cinquième candidature législatives dans
cette 4e circonscription du doubs
finaliste malheureuse en 2015 vous êtes
inclinés de seulement 8 163 voix
valernes et des bons jours à
voujeaucourt vous avez fondé le groupe
de concessions automobiles qui porte
votre nom près de 400 salariés répartis
sur huit sites en franchement
et en politique vous revendiquez le
visage du renouvellement même si vous
êtes depuis 18 mois
conseiller régional l'est républicain de
bourgogne franche comté
nadia bars ni cas bonjour vous êtes
professeur des écoles directrice d'une
école primaire sur le quartier des buis
à valentigney après un long parcours
syndical vous franchissez le pas de la
politique
en vous présentant à cette élection
législative sous les couleurs de la
france
insoumise c'est votre première
candidature à une élection nationale
christine besançon enfin vous êtes maman
de six enfants thérapeute de profession
mais candidate à plein temps vous êtes
présenté à diverses élections régionales
départementales municipales d'abord sans
étiquette après un passage furtif au
modem puis aux côtés de boue la france
depuis les dernières régionales dont
vous êtes émancipé il ya peu révolté par
l'accord de nicolas dupont aignan avec
le front national
vous êtes également conseillère
municipale à audincourt et conseillère
communautaire un pays de montbéliard
agglomération voilà pour les cinq
candidats présents je vous précise que
sont également candidats sur cette 4e
circonscription du doubs youssouf c'est
in
anna maillard gaël pierron corinne
riquet antonio sanchez et michel treppo
christophe avons l'honneur alors ma
première et ma première question va vers
vous frédéric barbier
vous avez donc la double investiture
mais c'est une question davantage sur le
climat de cette campagne comment vous
vivez cette campagne où certains de vos
amis socialistes nourrissent à votre
égard un certain potentiel un
ressentiment un ressentiment mais
important des mots parfois très dures
sont lâchés pas facile de faire campagne
dans ce dans ce climat de défiance
non mais je pense que les partis
traditionnels connaissent une crise
énorme et derrière il y aura une
reconstruction
je comprends que certains soient en
train de chercher leur voix chercher
leur leur chemin en même temps me
concernant dans mes pratiques
j'ai l'habitude de rassembler les gens
de travailler au delà des clivages
politiques c'est comme ça qu'on a réussi
à faire aboutir un certain nombre de
dossiers et donc voilà je crois que tout
naturellement le parti socialiste parce
que je suis un homme de gauche m'a
apporté son soutien son investiture il
l'a maintenue et puis la république en
marche parce qu'ils connaissent mes
pratiques mais façon de travailler que
ce soit l'assemblée nationale où sur le
territoire
on souhaitait également
me soutenir dans cette dette quand
certains de vos amis socialistes ou font
des reproches assez dur ça ne vous
atteint pas non je pense que encore une
fois ça fait partie du débat
quand je dis que les partis
traditionnels traversent une crise
et effectivement il ya une crise à
l'intérieur et il est certain je redis
sont en train de chercher un chemin une
voie et c'est le débat ça me paraît
normal
je crois que vous savez ce que le streak
occupe qu'il ya un grand écart entre
mais aujourd'hui et on va vous demander
une question et personnelle mais très
précises pour qui vous avez voté au
premier tour de la présidentielle
écoutez je suis légaliste et donc
j'avais dit que je soutiendrai et j'ai
parrainé benoît hamon j'ai parrainé
benoît hamon parce que je suis
socialiste et donc j'ai voté pour lui au
premier tour de cette élection
présidentielle mais en faisant savoir
que sur son programme je pouvais avoir
aussi un certain nombre de différences
voilà et sanaa vous avez remarqué que ça
n'a pas du tout gêné la république en
marche
emmanuel macron de me donner sous la
dictature est de me soutenir
merci frédéric barbier sophie montel
vous êtes donc à nouveau candidate sur
cette 4e circonscription depuis 2002 une
circonscription où vous n'habitez pas on
l'a beaucoup répéter et où on n'a pas
l'impression vous fassiez vraiment
campagne
est-ce que vous contenter de surfer sur
une vague de mécontentement car c'est
marrant parce que cette histoire de dire
que je n'habite pas la circonscription
je vous rappelle quand même que nous
sommes en élections législatives je l'
ai entendu depuis 2002 je n'habite pas
cette circonscription
oulala à la vilaine elle n'habite pas la
circonscription s'agit d'élire des
députés monsieur chevreuil vous l'avez
dit vous-même lors d'un petit spot que
vous avez réalisé qu est ce qu un député
un député c'est quelqu'un qui va aller
voter des lois à l'assemblée nationale
c'est un représentant de la nation
voilà c'est pas un monsieur ou une dame
qui ce qui toutes les semaines va couper
des rubans va inaugurer telle ou telle
chose tel ou de tel parc d'attractions
part que vers voilà un député doit voter
les lois à l'assemblée nationale donc je
me présente sur cette circonscription
comme vous l'expliqué depuis c'est la
cinquième fois depuis le et j'ai vécu
toute ma jeunesse toute mon enfance sur
cette circonscription je ne me sens pas
comment dire illégitime à me présenter
sur cette circonscription vous faites
encore le résultat lors de l'élection
partielle ou vouloir vous l'avez rappelé
tout à l'heure nous avons loupé
l'élection à 8 163 voix ce qui était
vraiment une élection dans un mouchoir
pour monsieur barbier oui
mais monsieur bec moi je ne me trimballe
pas avec les journalistes derrière moi
pour faire des remarques l'âge
non je ne fais pas une campagne en
cachette je fais une campagne aux pros
plus près de la population ce qui
m'intéresse ce sont les électeurs ce ne
sont pas les journalistes je suis désolé
de vous le dire mais c'est la réalité je
fonctionne comme ça et je continuerai de
fonctionner comme ça ça a très bien
marché dans l'ordre d'un certain nombre
d'élections moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est
le ressenti nos compatriotes et je dois
dire que sur cette circonscription le
ressenti est particulièrement inquiétant
aujourd'hui sophie montel vous êtes
députée européenne conseillère régionale
si vous êtes élu député de la nation
pour conserver ses mandats au bond en
monsieur chevreuil j'ai tout gardé
vous savez très bien tous les ans vous
savez très bien comme moi que si demain
je suis élu député à l'assemblée
nationale de fait je perds mon mandat de
député et pour la loi et je quitterai
mon mandat de conseillère régionale
stressant d'opposition bien sûr mais
bien sûr oui mais ça va mieux en le
disant
c'est très amusant valérie des vous
présenter comme le candidat du renouveau
à 61 ans vous avez un parcours
d'entrepreneur accompli pourquoi cette
candidature vous n'avez plus rien à
prouver et en quoi vous êtes le candidat
du renouveau
alors je suis le candidat du renouveau
le candidat du renouveau ça veut pas
dire jeuniste ça veut dire un petit peu
ce que préconise aujourd'hui notre
président de la république des personnes
qui viennent de la société civile
aujourd'hui je prétends que j'avais
toute légitimité et de me présenter
pourquoi cette circonscription elle m'a
vu naître il m'a vu grandir
elle m'a vu faire mes études elle a vu
elle m'a vu ma veste ir dans mes
entreprises valernes aider vous citez
d'emblée emmanuel macron ça veut dire
que vous êtes un candidat pro macron
également comme frédéric barbier non pas
du tout c'est la campagne au jour de ces
le programme de notre président 2
2 prenez de dire qu' il ya des candidats
des candidats de la société civile c'est
à dire que c'est ce qu'ils demandent
dans son gouvernement si vous êtes élu
député de cette 4ème circonscription du
doubs est ce que vous aurez le temps
d'assumer toutes vos responsabilités
notamment à la tête du groupe né des
alors j'ose espérer que vous ne puissiez
pas penser qu'une entreprise avec 400
personnes ne soient pas structurée à
travers un staff déjà depuis
pratiquement plus de 10 ans à travers un
directeur général à travers des
directeurs suffirait qu'il m'arrive un
accident quelque chose il faut que
l'entreprise tourne donc automatiquement
on a quand même une structure qui me
permet de libérer du temps pour cette
circonscription
et en plus je démissionnerai de mon
poste de conseiller régional auprès de
la région nadia bars ni cas le front
national on l'a dit on l'a répété
prospère sur cette terre industrielle au
contraire de la france insoumise puisque
jean luc mélenchon a réalisé un score
inférieur à sa moyenne nationale sur la
quatrième du doubs est ce que cela
signifie que vous avez perdu le combat
des ouvriers
je ne pense pas que nous ayons perdu le
combat des ouvriers je pense que
beaucoup d'entre eux reconnaissent dans
ce que propose le programme l'avenir en
commun nous avons du travail à faire et
nous le faisons sur le terrain nous
allons discuter avec les ouvriers avec
la population pour ré expliquer notre
programme qui est un programme de
progrès social qui est un programme
écologique et je reviens au progrès
social
nous avons des propositions sérieuses
sur l'emploi nous avons des propositions
sur l'augmentation des salaires nous
avons des propositions sérieuses sur une
vie digne
nous avons des propositions importantes
sur l'accès aux soins le droit à
l'éducation et je pense qu'il nous faut
continuer à discuter avec la population
avec nos concitoyens pour leur expliquer
que nous sommes la solution qu'il faut
pour toulon encore une fois il ya une
énorme dit
à la gauche du parti socialiste en plus
de votre candidature est une candidate
communiste une écologiste un communiste
révolutionnaire un candidat lutte
ouvrière pourquoi france insoumise
n'arrive pas à fédérer
alors déjà à la gauche du parti
socialiste je ne suis pas tout à fait
d'accord avec la façon dont vous
l'exprimez puisque nous ne savons plus
trop où est le parti socialiste dans la
circonscription
en tout cas il serait tout à gauche qu'à
droite oui ça c'est sûr l'éparpillement
des candidatures à gauche c'est pas une
nouveauté ça a toujours été le cas il ya
toujours eu des candidatures de
témoignage comme 10,7 du pc se
rapprocher de france ans mu écoutez le
pc a fait des appels de pied un peu tout
le monde sur la troisième
circonscription ils soutiennent la
candidate ps
cet après midi ils ont soutenu le
programme de la france un soumise à la
présidentielle maintenant ils
soutiennent un autre programme donc
leur position est difficile à comprendre
nous nous sommes rassembleur nous leur
avons fait des propositions sur notre
programme parce que pour nous c'est ça
qui compte le programme que nous
défendons et en lequel on croit
christine besançon une question
également sur les étiquettes puisque
vous étiez jadis au modem dans le jura
puis apparenté ump aujourd'hui debout la
france depuis les régionales une
étiquette avec laquelle vous semblez
prendre de la distance aujourd'hui alors
où êtes vous libre et indépendante mais
solitaire
ah non pas solitaires je suis toujours à
titre personnel je suis toujours
candidate des nefs je suis toujours au
sein de la famille d'élèves nicolas
dupont aignan a pris une certaine
position
il était libre tout autant que je suis
une femme libre
ils étaient libres de prendre cette
décision il a engagé le parti quand même
il a pas gâcher le party
suite il ne nous a pas appelés appelé je
vous assure il ne nous a pas appelés de
toute façon à voter front national on a
été libre de notre vote
et contrairement à tous ceux qui ont
rallié macron quand même contrairement à
tous ceux qui ont rallié macron sans
aucune aucune discussion sans enlever un
point quel qu'il soit qui n'étaient pas
acceptables dans le gouvernement de
macron
donc enfin d'andorre dans son projet en
tous les cas vous savez quand même je
voudrais dire quelque chose c'est que je
suis une candidate parce que le peuple
je suis candidate aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui parce que nos concitoyens
ont besoin d'une réelle proximité et
notre circonscription a besoin aussi de
candidats mais parlons de monsieur
barbier qui a voté le 15 décembre 2015
un amendement contre l'amendement numéro
340 vous de vous en souvenir monsieur
barbier vous étiez nouvellement élu à
bowser amendement 340 1 qui permettait
de lutter de façon très efficace contre
la fraude fiscale des entreprises
la fraude fiscale des entreprises c'est
60 à 70 milliards d'euros
christine besançon j'ai posé une
question personnelle et particulière à
frédéric barbier tout à l'heure je vais
vous poser la même et pour le deuxième
tour est ce qu'on peut savoir pour bien
comprendre pour qui vous allez voter au
deuxième tour de la présidentielle qui
j'ai voté
j'ai voté blanc merci merci on va tout
de suite faire rentrer notre collègue de
l'est républicain sébastien michaud
[Musique]
sébastien qui s'installe sébastien vous
avez dix minutes pour interroger nos
candidats sur une question évidemment
centrale dans cette circonscription va
parler automobile là on va parler
automobile économie emploi parce que la
4e circonscription est indissociable de
psa sochaux qui s'avère le poumon de 7,6
recours alors madame montée il fut un
temps où communiquer plus abondamment
sur sur psa alors c'est pas ça semble
vieux parce qu'il ya beaucoup de choses
qui ont changé depuis
c'était il ya trois ans le groupe était
alors au bord du gouffre c'est pour ça
que ça semble un peu une éternité alors
à l'époque vous dénonciez
les effets néfastes de l'europe
aujourd'hui le groupe va mieux à renouer
avec avec les avec les bénéfices aux
actionnaires annoncé un annoncé un plan
d'investissement de 200 millions sur le
site de sochaux où on fabrique la 3008
qui est le véhicule de l'année je
voulais savoir un peu de quel regard
vous portiez sur cette évolution du
groupe et et du site psa sochaux depuis
la situation de psa s'est amélioré en
tout cas en façade puisque l'état ça ne
vous a pas échappé est entré au capital
ainsi que le constructeur dongfeng donc
ce qui a permis de réoxygéner
l'entreprise ps enfin le groupe psa moi
il ya il reste des points
d'interrogation il reste des points
noirs dans cette ce mot cette belle
image qu'on nous qu'on nous montre
aujourd'hui
d'abord le fait que psa continue comme
renault d'ailleurs comme nos
constructeurs automobiles continuent à
dégraisser ses effectifs dans l'hexagone
puisque ce sont à peu près 5000 départ à
la retraite ou heures départ anticipé
qui sont proposées chaque année le plan
continue je note aussi que psa ne fait
absolument pas d'efforts pour cimenter
les emplois puisque on se base
il ya des offres d'emploi effectivement
mais ce sont des offres sur l'intérim
écueil et le nombre de la proportion de
cdi dans l'usiné même de ce show est
assez faible puisque nous sommes de
l'ordre d'à peu près 5000 personnes sur
un effectif qui a peu près de 10000 donc
il ya des difficultés réelles dans le
groupe ne nous voyons voilons pas la
face et je note aussi mediapart a sorti
un article cette semaine je m'étonne
d'ailleurs que la presse n'ait pas fait
plus l'écho
psa renault et auchan ont réussi à
s'exonérer de 141 millions d'euros
d'impôts en france en expatriés en leur
wii en expatriés à malte leur gestion
d'assurance voilà c'est tout cet argent
là ne rentre pas dans les caisses de
l'état français voilà effectivement pour
l'instant mais ça va mieux ce qui
n'enlève rien à la con fait une bonne
nouvelle quand même on peut le dire
évidemment je ne vais pas je n'en mets
ça mais je dis qu'il reste des points
d'interrogation et que tant qu'on ne
mettra pas en place le protectionnisme
économique
eh bien nous nous exposerons nos
industries en particulier la filière
automobile à une concurrence qui est
particulièrement déloyale et sébastien
fait tourner à part monsieur barbier
qu'est-ce que quel regard portez vous
sur l'évolution je sais que à ce niveau
là vous avez fait des demandes notamment
pour la demande de cdi 1 vous êtes
intervenu plusieurs fois sur la
problématique du travail intérimaire
aujourd'hui quel chemin parcouru
quand même en 2012 on était au bord de
la faillite j'ai pas vu madame montel
s'emparer du dossier
moi j'ai consacré j'y ai consacré des
heures c'est quoi ça crée des heures des
jours et des nuits en ouvrant jeudi en
ouvrant les portes dans les ministères
on y travaillant avec bien sûr ici en
travaillant bien sûr avec la direction
avec les organisations syndicales
mais quelle redressement aujourd'hui
c'est je crois qu'il faut pas bouder son
plaisir par rapport à ça oui il y a
encore trop l'intérim
il y aura mille emplois d'intérim qui
sont proposés sur le site de psa mille
également dans la sous traitance est
donc le pays non bélières va mieux
il reste deux inquiétudes effectivement
le niveau des salaires qui encore trop
bas et puis la précarité et bien
derrière il faut y travailler
mais quand on investit 200 millions
d'euros sur le site sur les cinq
prochaines années quant à la pérennité
qu'on a la fierté je veux dire que je
partage avec l'ensemble des salariés sur
le sur le 3008
quand on a une pérennité parce que quand
on investit durable aussi fortement sur
un site c'est effectivement pour
derrière pour le faire durer quand ça
deviendra le site le plus performant de
l'industrie automobile au niveau
européen
oui une certaine fierté mais par contre
il faut travailler 1 sur la précarité et
je demande sans cesse et je me bats sur
effectivement les cdi depuis derrière le
niveau des salaires ça on va interroger
quelqu'un qui connaît bien avec la
flexibilité va faire pardonner les bras
roulé mais paraissent sociaux montrent l
on va interroger quelqu'un qui connaît
bien les véhicules peugeot va leur nez
dès ce que vous êtes d'accord 1
avec ces deux affirmations qu'on a
entendu psa va mieux et le problème
c'est qu'il ya encore trop d'intérim
alors un effet comme vous le savez et
psa va mieux puisqu'on a produit phare
quatre minutes
mais aujourd'hui vous le savez dans le
monde industriel
c'est comme ça se passe un petit peu
dans le monde
on marche un petit peu à coup
d'accordéon c'est à dire qu'on a des
ascendants c'est le cas actuellement
mais ce qu'il faut donner au niveau des
cdi au niveau des entreprises et ça va
répondre un peu à madame montaigne et
puis à monsieur le député surtemps c'est
qu'il faut donner la flexibilité de
l'agilité et de la souplesse la réforme
du code du travail ou aussi je suis pour
l'amélioration du code du travail
je ne suis pas pour la réforme du code
du travail je suis pour que l'ags le
code du travail soit en concertation
pour l'améliorer vous n'êtes pas sans
savoir que au niveau des hauts niveaux
des cdd cdi et des cdd contrats à durée
déterminée c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui il
ya mille emplois au niveau de chez
peugeot qui sont demandées et vous avez
1000 entre emplois au niveau des sous
traitants ce qu'il faut qu'on donne
c'est la flexibilité
quand je parle de souplesse de pouvoir
continuer et faire perdurer ces contrats
au delà de 18 outre en bois
l'amélioration l'amélioration du niveau
du code du travail j'imagine que ça va
faire réagir la gabarre smic à sophie
montel vous êtes largement en avance sur
le temps de parole je vous demande est
dit est possible nous réclamons
clairement l'abrogation de la loi
travail
je voudrais revenir sur ce qui vient
d'être dit sur la flexibilité et peugeot
sochaux aujourd'hui c'est 8915 salariés
et 1381 intérimaire
c'est énorme à la france insoumise on
dit qu'il faut un maximum de 5% de la
masse salariale qu'ils soient des
intérimaires pour une grande industrie
et ça on peut l'imposer en emploi et on
peut voter des lois
je pense que c'est une politique à mener
il faudra en discuter mais ce que je
voulais dire revenir à la flexibilité
moi ce qui m'importe aussi ce sont les
salariés dans l'est républicain de
hyères
on parlait de les ouvriers sont au bord
de la crise de nerfs ce n'est plus
possible
l'entreprise dégage des bénéfices pour
les actionnaires mais n'apporte pas
grand chose aux ouvriers et pourtant ce
sont les ouvriers qui font la richesse
de l'entreprise on augmente le temps de
travail
on leur demande de travailler plus
longtemps pour la tournée nuit on
diminue le temps de pause
tout ça pour favoriser la sortie de la
voiture qui est en vogue en ce moment
or la flexibilité et le salarié pressé
comme un citron on y est déjà depuis
longtemps je ne sais pas jusqu'où ça
pour aller mais il est grave c'est une
besançon vous partagez cet avis est
également rapide alors moi je bon je
pense que il ya eu suffisamment
d'interprétation concernant psa sochaux
moi je pense aujourd'hui à pépé et mpc
je suis très inquiet pour pmtc j'avais
eu tort mais je scooter j'allais me
suces pour les jonquilles code voilà
j'allais dire que je scooter donc qui se
trouve sur les communes de mandeure je
suis très inquiète malgré une forte
hausse
un jaune n'est plus le même match mr
majeur désormais malgré malgré une forte
hausse du dernier set à 3 roues un
scooter 3 roues metropolis je crois
qu'ils se nomment un ya une forte hausse
des ventes actuellement mais moi je
crains que ça ne soit qu'une éclaircie
alors personne ne le dit mais quand même
personne n'en parle il ya quand même un
il ya quand même un souci voilà on n'a
pas un certain mois après les
législatives pour en parler mais il ya
quand même un gros gros soucis cette
entreprise risque quand même de faire
mais personne ne le dit dans ce canard
que deviendront les employés que
deviendront les salariés moi je veux le
savoir est ce que psa on reprendra une
partie est ce que les prendrons tous que
deviendront-ils dans ce cas là que
deviendra aussi le site 1 à mandeure
donc je pense que le travail des élus
qui seront ils eurent tous les cas sur
cette circonscription
ce sera effectivement de pensée pour eux
mais pour l'avenir
merci que c'est une boisson merci
sébastien pour ce qu'ils sont
il n'était pas d'accord a effectivement
on accueille christophe bec tout de
suite alors christ vous écoutiez dans la
coulisse nos cinq candidats es ce que
vous avez un droit de suite à exercer
des choses à préciser avec quelques-uns
d'entre eux oui je m'adresser afrique
barbier concernant les les accords à psa
qui ont emporté un peu de souplesse le
ncs nouveau contrat social et de nouvel
élan pour la croissance
alors pour aller un petit peu plus loin
une idée avancée par le président la
république c'est cette deuxième mouture
de la loi travail vous avez vous même
été déjà interrogatif sur la première
mouture qu'est ce que vous pensez de
cette deuxième mouture la loi travail
est-ce que vous la vôtre et lorsque vous
serez si vous êtes député de la majorité
présidentielle vous faire très simple
qui sauvent mec j'ai pas été
interrogatif sur la première mouture
j'étais content je me suis opposé et je
me suis exprimé à plusieurs reprises sur
ce sujet là et la deuxième que je note
ce que je note sur la deuxième c'est que
premièrement les organisations
syndicales ont été reçues par le
président de la république et par le
premier ministre je n'ai pas entendu
effectivement je veux dire en tout cas
de la part des organisations syndicales
tant de reproches que ça c'est à dire
que pour l'instant ils attendent est
sorti une idée de la part de la cfdt qui
dit donnons nous le temps et moi je
l'appuierai dans cette direction prenons
effectivement le temps de cette
discussion mais simplement je te dis sur
jms l'entreprise allait mal le
gouvernement s'en est saisi et les
commandes sont arrivées et derrière sur
saint nazaire également là on a
réaffirmé le soin de protéger les
salariés
sophie montel vous réclamez des vrais
enfin sophie montel elle a déjà beaucoup
parlé elle est d'accord avant et vous
avez un droite avec la valeur n'est des
vous parliez de coups d'accordéon dans
l'industrie automobile
on constate aujourd'hui qu'il ya
effectivement beaucoup de postes en
recrutement même si son intérimaire et
on a du mal à trouver quels dispositifs
mettre en place pour y pour justement
permettre ce recrutement plus plus
facile de 2000 voire 2500 personnes
autour de l'industrie automobile à
montbéliard alors c'est vrai tout
d'abord ce que je veux dire parce que
j'ai eu le temps de terminer avec
les intervenants c'est qu'aujourd'hui je
suis pratiquement le seul qui peut
parler emploi parce que j'ai créé des
emplois
vous allez faisons et vous avez les 10 e
je pense que les emplois je les connais
je les fais ça a été des milliers
d'emplois sur les trois dernières
décennies et vous trouvez à recruter
facilement aujourd'hui c'est
relativement difficile je vous la corde
pourquoi parce qu'on a perdu
la valeur travail on a perdu la
formation on a perdu l'apprentissage
l'apprentissage a perdu ses lettres de
noblesse parce que l'apprentissage a
toujours voulu souvent dire échec
scolaire qu'en réalité il faut revenir à
l'apprentissage à la peau conseil
régional nouveautés qu'outre pas du tout
même ciel quand le front national
propose des amendements ou d'émotion sur
le retour à la revalorisation du métier
manuel vous votez contre valeur n'est
des répondait rapidement et après on
passe aux conclusions s'il vous plaît
voté contre alors non pas six heures
vérifiable
on regardera sur les comptes rendus de
conseils régionaux vous avez chacun 45
secondes on arrive au terme de
l'émission ça passe très très vite
on commence avec vous christine besançon
45 secondes pour convaincre les
électeurs qui voteront dimanche prochain
je vous invite
mesdames et messieurs des électeurs à
voter pour quelqu'un qui n'aura pas la
langue de bois qui n'hésitera pas à se
déplacer pour agir efficacement
je voulais prouver chaque jour en me
rendant à votre domicile sont les 56
communes de la 4e circonscription du
doubs je voulais prouver aussi depuis
trois ans que je suis élue d'opposition
sur les communes de d'un courant
répondant systématiquement à toutes vos
interpellations
je ne me suis jamais dérobé vous pouvez
compter sur moi merci christine besançon
dania barzani cas je voulais venir un
tout petit peu sur psa en disant qu' il
ya bientôt 50 ans en 1968
des ouvriers se battait pour obtenir des
augmentations de salaires des ouvriers
manifestaient pour l'amélioration de
leurs conditions de travail et il y en a
deux qui sont morts pour ça on a
l'impression que nous n'avons pas
beaucoup avancé depuis ce temps là et
qu'il faut conserver les acquis que les
ouvriers les salariés se sont battus
pour défendre
si vous votez pour la france
mise nous défendrons notre programme qui
est un programme l'avenir en commun
écologique social et humain merci nadia
bernicat valernes et des électrices et
électeurs
si je suis élu au soir du 18 juin je
serai là pour apporter votre parole
votre parole à l'assemblée nationale je
ne serai pas là pour dit de faire passer
les diktats du national
je serai là pour vous pour soutenir les
habitants les 56 circonscriptions et je
serai là également pour soutenir les
projets des collectivités locales les
projets des entreprises et je suis issu
de cette terre cette terre qui m'est
cher cette terre ouvrière qui m'a vu nez
et investir merci valernes et des sophie
montel
moi je dirais aux téléspectateurs à mes
frères compatriotes qu'il faut élire sur
cette circonscription comme dans
l'ensemble des circonscriptions un
député patriotes qui protégera la france
et qui défendra les intérêts de nos
compatriotes à l'assemblée nationale je
suis né dé se trompent
un député ça vote les lois ça ne
représente pas le territoire sur lequel
il est élu il défend l'intérêt général
l'intérêt suprême de la nation
moi je vois aujourd'hui des candidats
qui sont macron compatit vous avez
monsieur l'aider tout à l'heure qui nous
a expliqué qu'il pourrait très bien et
avoir l'étiquette macron pourquoi pas
monsieur barbier qui fait de recyclage
socialiste avec l'étiquette macron parce
que c'est dans l'air du temps ça permet
une réflexion
moi j'ai dit à nos compatriotes
aujourd'hui nous nous approchons d'un
chaos social avec notamment la loi de
cette nouvelle loi et le comme ricky
passera par ordonnance qui veut la
flexibilité la dérégulation totale
imposée par bruxelles je terminerai en
vous expliquant à vitré dans les cartons
d'union européenne il y a le fait de
vouloir supprimer le cdi en france
frédéric barbier je suis le député
sortant je suis un député de terrain qui
travaille aux côtés des salariés je suis
moi-même à l'effectif de mon entreprise
en disponibilité en congé sans solde je
ne lâche rien et je ne lâcherai rien
dans ce futur mandat je suis aussi le
candidat de la majorité présidentielle
il faut donner une majorité à emmanuel
macron il a fait ses débuts il est il
règne sur la planète en ce qui concerne
l'écologie l'environnement
il est légal ses premiers pas ont été
réussis je crois fondamentalement qu'il
ne faut pas aller vers une cohabitation
je n'ai pas vu valernes et dé prendre de
distance par rapport à l'appel à voter
sur fion et derrière ci s'est imposée
effectivement un blocage bloquer un
combat systématique
je suis le candidat de cette majorité et
il faut donner une majorité à emmanuel
maquet maire si frédéric barbier merci à
tous les singles je vous laisse voir
l'ensemble des autres candidats sur
cette circonscription youssouf cet hymne
anna maillard gehl pierron corinne
riquet antonio sanchez et michel treppo
merci christophe merci à sébastien
véronique et frédéric je vous donne
rendez vous cet après midi pour deux
nouveaux débats à 15h sur internet on
ira à dole dans le jura et à montbéliard
dans le doubs à cet après midi
[Musique]